and Tanglin is often blamed for the
spooky weirdness of quantum mechanics in
this video I'll explain what it really
is and one of the coolest consequences
the EPR paradox if you ever watch today
is my other videos on quantum mechanics
you might want to watch these two but
I'll have a really quick recap for
everyone's benefit there are only two
quantum rules that we need to give us
entanglement the first is the
superposition rule it says that if there
are several options for an object and
there's no way that anything could know
what option the object is really doing
then it is in a superposition of doing
all of them now importantly this is very
different from saying it is doing one or
the other but we don't know which for
example if you flip the coin you may not
know whether it's heads or tails but
this doesn't mean it's in a
superposition you know the coin is one
or the other but you're not sure which a
superposition is a state where a
particle seems to really be doing both
at the same time at least in some
interpretations of quantum mechanics
then there's the measurement rule that
if you measure a particle that's in a
superposition it must collapse to just
one of the options in its superposition
here's how all of this can naturally
lead to entanglement we'll take an
example using spin but if you don't know
what that is don't worry too much
imagine we have a very energetic
particle of light then using Einstein's
famous formula it can convert that
energy into mass for example it could
form two new particles but there are a
bunch of conservation laws in physics
that restrict what these particles are
and what they do for example a photon
has no electrical charge so these new
particles should have no net charge so
one could be an electron but then the
other has to be a positive version of
electron a positron so that in total
their charge is zero but there's also a
thing called conservation of spin
photons never have any spin but both
electrons and positrons do they can
either have spin up which is positive
or spin-down which is negative so for
their total spin to cancel one should be
up and the other down but which way is
which usually you'd want to say it's one
of these ways but you don't know which
however remember in quantum mechanics if
there is no way to know then it must be
a superposition of both this state is
entangled but you may not see what's so
special about it yet entanglement is the
crazy property that it's impossible to
describe the state of one of these
particles without mentioning the other
to see what this means and why it's
unique to quantum mechanics let's
compare it to the knot quantum scenario
so classically we think it has to be one
or the other of these cases but not both
it's just that we don't know which here
if I wanted to describe the state of the
electron it would be up if the positron
is down and down if the positron is up
this seems like it fits my definition of
entanglement it's impossible to describe
the state of the electron without
talking about the positron so why isn't
this entanglement because really the
particles are just doing one thing let's
say this one if I knew that then I could
say the electron is up it's only because
I didn't know which case it is that I
had to describe them like this but in
the quantum case there isn't this way
out the particles are apparently doing
both of these things and so there isn't
an actual state of the electron that we
can talk about the electron is not
actually just up it's both up if the
other is down and down if the other is
up you can never talk about the state of
these particles separately only their
joints feet that's entanglement but you
might have an objection to this current
you say that the electron state is a
superposition of up and down well there
are two ways to show that this isn't the
state of the electron the first is just
mathematically showing that these two
states aren't equal but that's a little
bit boring so instead let's see that
this could lead to a contradiction
suppose Alice takes the electron and Bob
takes the positron
we'll assume that the state of Alice's
particle is a superposition of up and
down and the state of bulbs particle is
the same if this is actually true then
this lets us describe the state of each
particle separately without mentioning
the other one then say Alice measures
hers and finds it to be up and so her
state collapses but Bob doesn't he can
measure his and can still get up as well
this means they start with a photon with
zero spin and they get two particles
with positive spin which breaks that
conservation law so no the total state
can't be written as these two individual
states the real state is this
combination and what really happens is
Alice measures hers and Faye gets the
result up then that collapses the
superposition to just this bit so now
Bob will definitely measure down and the
total spin is still conserved so we see
that we have to believe that the
particles are entangled to explain this
it was unspent those who realized the
extraordinary consequences of
entanglement and it's very simple let's
get Alice and Bob to go very far away
from each other and then do the exact
same experiment notice something Alice's
measurement of her particle effects
Bob's particle because Bob's has to be
the opposite but even worse that effect
has to be instant because if Bob
measures his particle a split second
after Alice he needs to still get the
opposite result so there can't be any
delay in how quickly Alice's measurement
effects bulbs somehow the message from
Alice's electron to the positron
traveled instantly in other words this
effect is non-local the issue is that
this seems to contradict Einstein's
theory of relativity in that theory no
information can travel faster than light
and the reason is that if it could then
you could cause things like time travel
and the grandfather paradox I'm saying
thought that this would be enough to
convince people that quantum
Darry is silly but what really happened
was the scientific community of the time
weren't able to come up with a good
answer to it and instead just decided to
ignore it it wasn't until much later
that people cared and even later that it
was proved that the sort of spooky
action at a distance in quantum
mechanics doesn't allow time paradoxes
since Alice can never send any messages
to Bob through this mechanism but partly
because of the nonlocality in quantum
mechanics it still doesn't sit very
comfortably with the theory of
relativity thanks for watching this
video so here are some homework
questions for you to try and answer in
the comments firstly explain why alice
can never send any messages through this
setup second this one is to practice
working with wave functions of several
objects prove mathematically that it's
impossible to write our state as two
separate states for the electron and
positron and third this one is very
relevant to quantum computing if you
have just one electron or positron you
only need two numbers to describe its
state now suppose that you have n of
them if they're not entangled how many
numbers do you need to describe their
state what about a general state that is
allowed to be entangled